hi this is Becca from Khan Academy and
today I'm going to be talking about
temperance so what was the temperance
movement in this video I'll talk a
little bit about what temperance was
what its causes were and how it started
to develop in the early 1800's
temperance was the idea that Americans
drank way too much alcohol and needed to
temper their consumption it started as
kind of this idea that people should
just drink a little bit less they should
drink less whiskey less run less hard
alcohol and then slowly it started to
take on this kind of prohibitory
character so again it was the idea that
we just needed to temper our alcohol
consumption and so how did the
temperance movement take root the
temperance movement kind of has three
main causes that I like to think about
so the three main causes were the Second
Great Awakening the Industrial
Revolution and growing nativism and
frankly racism that started as new
immigrants were coming to America in the
early 1800s so this was all kind of
happening right around here and so I'll
talk a little bit more about each of
these causes for the temperance movement
and how it began so I'll start by
talking about the Second Great Awakening
so the Second Great Awakening was this
time period in the early 1800s that
focused a lot of social reforms around
capturing moral good or Christian ideals
so Christian ideals here's the cross
within our social institutions so this
happened in education in prisons in the
first women's rights movement and so
this was all going on in the 1800s and
it was about this idea that we needed to
be good and moral people and we needed
our social institutions to reflect that
so temperance can be seen as a part of
the second great awakening and so down
here you can kind of see the Second
Great Awakening image here this is the
idea that the family was also intimately
affected by people being too drunk
here's like the father and he's really
drunk and things are kind of going
- mayhem people were just too drunk and
this was tearing apart lots of different
institutions including the family
including education including the
workplace and so that's a good
transition to talking about the
Industrial Revolution so the Industrial
Revolution was also going on at this
time period and people could no longer
be drunk on the job right so people used
to be artisans they used to just kind of
sit in their home make their shoes or
sew something by hand and they could be
drunk while doing that but now if you're
kind of in a factory setting people were
getting their fingers cut off by these
new machines that were up promoted in
the Industrial Revolution because they
were drunk while trying to operate the
machinery so with this new industry
workers could no longer be drunk on the
job and so the final causes this
nativism that people were seeing with
new Catholic immigrants so there were
Catholic immigrants coming into the
country and lots of Protestants were
very anti-catholic and anti-immigration
they decided that the Catholics were
drunks and they did drink a lot but he
was definitely this kind of racist
sentiment that was percolating within
the Protestant community and this kind
of aligned itself with the Whig party so
the Whigs became more Protestant they
were really big temperance people and
the Catholics more aligned themselves
with the Democrats the sentiment towards
these immigrant populations had this
kind of political effect so at this time
temperance was starting to become more
of a political movement and different
social groups were taking this more
seriously there were some state-level
organizations it was just becoming more
of a social phenomenon in 1825 right
over here this really famous preacher
Lyman Beecher did his six sermons on the
sins of alcoholic and so these sermons
in 1825 solidified this idea in the
American mind that it was anti-christian
to be a huge drinker and this idea
really took root this is becoming kind
of this larger social phenomenon
and there start to be not just more
state level or community level societies
against drinking you see the first ever
national organization so the first
national Temperance Society was in 1826
down here with the American Temperance
societies the 80s and I'll talk more
about the 80s and the kind of
nationalization of the temperance
movement in the next video